[Music]
[Applause]
it's books yeah i can't believe this one
didn't sell because it seems kind of fun
to me it's called u.s presidents as nhl
players
i just think that's fantastic
look at that
you got you got classic presidents
there's nixon battling it out playing
for the leaf he's just the leafs you got
lincoln
lincoln swallows fighting it out
wow no one seems particularly horrifying
in a hockey hack i know in a hockey
helmet i like this one a lot it's called
stormtroopers of napa valley this is
stormtroopers
chilling out
having a good time they're really having
a good time they're taking a nice walk
oh yeah they want a lady one's a lady
and look at that they're just why
shouldn't they have fun in that one i
think they should
that's what i think i wonder if they
just pour the wine in the vents and it
just trickles down
i'll work on it after the show you
continue
you might be busy drawing a penis uh
here's one that looks like a lot of fun
lions attacking douche bag wow
that guy deserves it yeah look at these
lines go after everybody look at that
guy really hasn't come in he's wearing
short shorts yeah and then of course oh
no
i don't approve of that he's just a
young canadian kid making his way he
sure is
this one's called
this one's called muppets i do
by academy award-winning actor nick
nolte
wow these are all and i'll tell you what
you think it's not authentic look it has
a note from him on the back i'd do every
one of these muppets sincerely
nick nolte
that's a personal it really is
even beaker now this one i can
understand why it didn't sell because
you have to really be a fan of magic i
mean really be a fan of magic to like
this next book it's called is this your
card oh wow
that's it that's it it's just is this
your card and look on the back
again is this your card and is this your
card wow
the whole
and look there's even a follow-up to
that one called
how about this one
they're just i mean
you're converting jurgen king look at
what that can't even make up a good fake
name
that's carrots
that's just laziness on the part what do
we do we need a name for that jurgen
bergen
i think they asked the writer who was
sleeping and that's what he said in his
sleep yeah looking [ __ ] look i'm
working
ladies and gentlemen you're gonna want
this one
michael douglas munching on actual
that's boxes pizza box yes that's it
it's all there he goes oh there he goes
he's really going to town and there he
is you just can't keep him awake he's
got the cold dead eyes of a shark
he's at work yeah yeah actual box
obviously there's part of a series what
here's michael douglas eating out down
south
chick-fil-a okay yeah
and finally michael douglas presents my
favorite
georgia o'keeffe paintings
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's an art lover
he loves art
everyone can have their money back if
they want